mein name ist luca und meine lieben
freunde ich höre gar kein deutsch rap
von daher wird das heutige video umso
interessanter denn wir reagieren heute
auf deutsche rapper ohne auto tune das
war mir egal ich hätte das komplette
video gestartet jetzt direkt mit
irgendwann der sinnvoll den voice craig
hat und im stimmbruch ist und keine
ahnung was aber apache ja das war heftig
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob mero dieser typ war wo
alle gesagt haben dass er irgendwie sich
klicks gekauft hat und likes und streams
und alles mögliche da gab es irgendwie
mal ne doku den trends als wirklich ich
bin überhaupt nicht drin in der szene
aber das klang gerade schon echt heftig
also heftig im sinne von heftig
beschossen und real taugt das ganze
video sich die stele lachen und denkst
du alter aber das ist ja alles so doch
künstlich man muss bei capital bei
allerdings natürlich auch sagen dass
seine musik jetzt nicht so so so dann
ist halt wirklich noch ja rapper so wie
man das halt nennen kann das andere was
er gerade hochgeladen wird es würde ich
eher so an die pop schiene packen auch
wieder gut also wir hatten ja apache zu
beginn schon kurz wo er wirklich dieses
kriminelle oder was auch immer da
irgendwie gesungen hat was er auch schon
mega krass war aber das wirklich auch
rap mäßig als ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung aber ich kann sagen wenn ich was
gut anhört und wenn nicht
[Musik]
wow
ich kann nur noch mal sagen ich dachte
ich lach mich hier schrott aber das war
eher unnormal krass dass die wohnung wo
wir wohnen kommt uns geht es gut er sei
besorgt dass brot
ich weiß nicht wer das ist
ob er irgendwie was nach gesundheit ob
selbst von ihm ist der trecker den er
gerade gesungen hat also wie bereits
gesagt ich kann mich überhaupt nicht aus
der deutschen rap-szene ich kennen die
großen namen aber sonst nichts als ich
bin jetzt nicht so insider mäßig drin
und ich möchte auch niemanden in seinem
musikgeschmack irgendwie angehen
aber das war jetzt nicht so krass dass
man natürlich auch sagen muss er sitzt
im auto und steht vielleicht im
startfenster jetzt kein bock in die laut
zu singen sowie capital brach oder wie
apache da in diesem tunnel oder so aber
es geht auf jeden fall emotionsgeladen
nach und besser würde ich sagen finde
ich ging auch klar
also natürlich klar alles hört sich
irgendwie besser mit auto schon an weil
kein musiker außer vielleicht jetzt
adele und chillen und khalid oder keine
ahnung was keiner trifft exakt die
perfekte tonhöhe den perfekt die
perfekte note et cetera pp es wird sich
selbstverständlich alles sehen wir immer
besser an und dann alle leute erstmal
die autotür nicht kennen das ist ein
plug in für musikproduktion software wie
logic oder fl studio oder keine ahnung
hat und dann kannst du halt damit ja
stimmen höhen angleichen jetzt hat der
atp
es ist quasi so eine art schiiten was
singen angeht und was rap man geht und
keine ahnung was aber hier jetzt in dem
video ich glaube das war auch mario fand
ich jetzt auch nicht so schlecht also
man hat auf jeden fall gemerkt dass er
floh hat ja man merkt glaube ich dass
ich absolut keine ahnung habe von
deutsch
[Musik]
klasse war nicht gut
ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt zeige dass
ich an ihm habe oder dass ich komplett
reinsch eis aber war das hamra ich
wirklich absolut keine ahnung
[Musik]
also man muss halt sagen er sei mit viel
mehr emotionen drin als der der wo ich
vor den namen nicht wusste also dass
findet er ja auch ganz gut obwohl
überhaupt hier muss man natürlich sagen
jetzt ist auch in einem studio
also du hast gute akustik er dass keine
leute drumherum wollte sich vielleicht
denkt das sind passanten jetzt reiche
nicht so laut allerdings muss man
natürlich auch sagen ich glaube dass es
dieser luciano logo das in seinen
liedern zumindest die ich mir jetzt
gerade mal angehört habe bei spotify
dass da überhaupt nichts oder vielleicht
reicht's nicht oder das gut gemacht mit
autotune bearbeitet wurde
so erteilt richtig und jetzt nicht so
mero mäßig ist hat apache was man halt
sagen muss es ging natürlich gut aber er
hat natürlich auch eine box mit dabei
und bei seinem ersten was wir eben den
tunnel hat natürlich auch ne fette box
oder das über irgendwie die lautsprecher
von seinem auto oder so an gemacht dann
ist man natürlich auch noch ein bisschen
mehr drin
zum beispiel irgendwie diese andere da
wo im auto saß dabei sind nur das war
echt komplett beschissen aber hätte
natürlich auch kein beat runter aber
trotzdem überzeugt mit apache bisher
voll und ganz
steigt der kokain akkus ich hatte die
wahl hat zwischen straße und natur jeden
taktisch fegefeuers optisch mit jeans
kraft sieht sich für die zeiten nachts
in der innenstadt schlecht also ich weil
ich selbst kann es auch nicht besser
aber das sind leute die hauptberuflich
machen und dafür nicht sagt jetzt nicht
so krass muss ich zugeben 2 mio lobten
bereich nicht sieht man zwar nicht auf
dem bett oder also ich hab schon voll
schrift das jetzt so deutsch apple
liebhaber darunter schreibt ordnung so
gut das sind alles meine vorbilder ja
wie bereits gesagt also ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung und dachte mir
hey vielleicht ist witzig wenn ich hoffe
ich rechtfertige mich die ganze zeit für
irgendwas wo ich mich noch gar nicht für
rechtfertigen muss also gut wir schon
weiter
du musst alle zu rasieren wollte bietet
bildmobil bruders sammler worte drauf
das ist ein falscher blick und des
autobauers ist dass du alles krass also
ich bin eigentlich kein fan von kapital
blasmusik aber hier muss man wirklich
sagen also ohne auto tune klingt es
wirklich krass also ich finde es
wirklich cool das hört sich fast genauso
an wie in seinen liedern also sehr
menschlich hätte ich hier jetzt nicht
mehr gesehen wurde er glaube ich bei
klasse dieser show war bei late night
berlin da kam mir auch sehr sympathisch
rüber aber mit der musik kann ich halt
nichts anfangen ich bin allgemein kein
deut ab hörer weil ich finde das hat
sich so verschlechtert über die letzten
jahre aber das ohne auto tuning da bin
ich begeistert vielleicht würde ich
einen anderen karriereweg einschlagen
möchten wir den ganzen ihrem diesen
betrieb
dass man sagen muss der bieter hört sich
mega kracher also wurde dann irgendwie
so das war echt krass aber die rf finde
ich nicht so gut
ich weiß nicht ob er bekannt ist oder ob
das von seinen instagram rapper ist oder
so könnt ihr mir gerne in die kommentare
schreiben aber wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten ganz kurze frage warum stehen
so viele rapper mit ihren ganzen
freunden dann da im hintergrund ich mein
bier talkshow du kannst doch auch
einfach allein vor der kamera stehen und
treffen da müssen jetzt nicht so die
ganzen leute so dahinter stehen ist das
so hey guck ich habe rücken genug dann
kommen die anderen hinter mir stehen
oder weil also ich versteh den sinn
einfach nicht so richtig
[Musik]
ich muss sagen es geht klar dafür dass
es ein freestyle ist wird man sich davor
ein bisschen was vorbereitet hat
allerdings wäre es natürlich auch mit
autotune schöner aber ich muss allgemein
sagen dass ich so was nicht höre und ja
aber für die situation war nicht ganz
neues flow ist gut kennt ihr noch
julians block machten noch videos ich
weiß ich aber nicht früher einmal so
repp bewertet von damals in wie kollegah
oder irgendwie so und so viel wie
kratzer passiert für mich sowie julius
blog ohne jegliche ahnung von der szene
um von der technik dahinter das waren
die deutsche rapper ohne auto zu
schreiben dann in die kommentare wird
dieses video bisschen hin angeschaut
er würde mich mal interessieren ja auf
jeden fall leute jetzt wird es richtig
gut zu werden und zwar wer war
eigentlich der beste rapper ohne auto
tune und diesem video
kapital brach durchsagen
der beste sänger
oder hat die beiden würde ich sagen ich
weiß nicht wie wir das gerne und in die
kommentare
würd mich auf jeden fall mega
interessieren hört ihr überhaupt sehr
viel deutsch aber so bei mir ist es so
ich höre gar kein deutsch web klar
zwangsläufig wegen dem club läuft dann
hört man es halt mit
allerdings ist es jetzt nicht so dass
ich sage puh ich geh jetzt duschen da
war ich erst mal neue album von dem
neuen treppe an wenn ich war direkt
schon gefallen da würde ich mir dort
über einen daumen hoch von euch unter
dem video freuen die bereits zu beginn
und auch in dem video 10.000 mal gesagt
ich möchte keine personen die
irgendwelche raptor persönlich angehen
oder beleidigen und ich möchte niemanden
von euch wenn ihr fanseite von einer
person wo ich gesagt habe finde ich
nicht so gut auch irgendwie angehen oder
verärgern oder so dass es einfach nur
meine meinung kann ja sein dass eine
andere meinung habt ich kann allerdings
sagen wenn wir etwas gut gefällt wenn
ich etwas gerne höre oder wenn ich etwas
ungern hören und das habe ich heute
getan ich habe dieses video hat seit
wochen vorgeschlagen bekommen so klingen
deutsch rapper und autotüren das ist
jetzt fast 1 million aufrufe von daher
dachte ich vielleicht wird es ein cooles
video hätte nicht gedacht dass ich so
positiv überrascht werde muss ich
allerdings auch zugeben zu machen
[Musik]